hey what's up i'm here interviewing
people
and it's going to be great where are you
from
egypt whoa hello how have you been
how are you where are you from i'm
i'm from new braunfels texas welcome to
texas no thank you i'm from seattle from
texas welcome to texas thank you
yeah you're welcome you're welcome what
are you doing what would you say is the
most texas thing about
texas um the fact that we say y'all
everybody says y'all
hey brendan schaub good to see you
we love you this is texas and we're here
tonight to welcome people here
hello welcome to texas
welcome to texas thank you
oh not me i'm from seattle oh really
well
nice to meet y'all welcome where are you
guys from tonight
we are uh we're from texas oh welcome to
texas
thank you thank you we love texas it's
amazing
what was st patrick famous for tonight
uh
he got the snakes out of ireland but wow
was from wales yeah in
korea there's it's full of snakes that's
what i call the communists
that make sense yeah they killed my
grandmother
it does hey guys hey welcome to texas
we're from sixth street blues on
youtube.com
okay i've heard of that at least since
you're new to tech austin you might have
left the mechanical bull then bro
yeah that's like 10 bucks
[Applause]
the door guys
i
[Music]
found out two things mechanical balls
cost ten dollars and taylor is a liar
how was shakespeare's pub it was awesome
love it was you guys like shakespeare or
what's
who's your favorite writer shakespeare
have you listened to shakespeare's
podcast
no no everyone should wear masks
like your cameraman is why aren't you
wearing one i'm going to wear one
that was my dad local open mic
what's up gangsters it's good to be here
my name is hans kim i have a asian penis
what's your name
if i if i were to walk outside
of this bar right now
what's your name anna lucia
you're heard of her first guys
hey nice hair my client is willing to
give an interview
awesome how do you feel about the
murders
hey how long have you guys been in this
intersection for
five seconds you know just a second
great where are you from
i'm from canadian texas so you say sorry
y'all
i say howdy brother interviewing for it
it's just for the love of the game love
it the game
taco bell live i love taco bell
do you love the gordita can you just say
it into the camera
i love the gordita chalupa can i say one
last thing
sure thing [ __ ] a ride in the [ __ ]
my brother's asian and he's the manliest
man out there holy [ __ ]
you know as an asian um we that's our
national theme song let's get down to
business
to defeat the highs
[Music]
ireland four sons
can you guys just say we love the
gordita chalupa from taco bell
yes we're gonna use all this we love the
gordita
chalupa from taco bell you always need
to bring a fortune cookie because we got
to stop the asian hate
yes that's how you stop it
can i ask why we're only talking about i
mean this is for this is a commercial
for taco bell
the [ __ ] out of here go
good morrow
what's up guys how's your night been
it's good
good good what'd you do
we went out and got a few drinks in a
couple places oh wow that's so cool
what's your favorite item to talk about
the
uh beefy frito bajita
brick that's a good choice you know our
viewers are really going to love that
and hey uh we're going to give this guy
some free taco bell today
uh so you know whenever you got to talk
about just mention my name you're going
to get free taco bell
what's your name uh i'll tell you later
that's we're uh interviewing people to
see you know whether you like
uh anal sex do you like anal sex into it
it's personally my thing but i'm gay so
i don't i don't know if they're biased
or not
do you have anything you want to promote
or [ __ ]
eat pray ass you pray us
we're with mtv what do you want to say
to our audience
not with mtv all right well what do you
okay we're not with mtv but what do you
want to say that was beautiful
do you have anything you want to say to
our audience what is your audience
uh they're mostly 13 year old girls
don't be prostitutes that's what i would
say to them if
a female wanted to use
an item on me i would be inclined to try
it i'm just here to
watch the people
talk to each other
hey what's up man how you been today um
pretty [ __ ] intoxicated that's good
to hear
my only regret is that i didn't get more
drunk
did you grind any on any honeys
absolutely i did okay [ __ ] ut
texas state baby eat him up eat him
hey eat him up hit him up bobcats he
didn't go to he didn't yeah
he didn't go hey did you graduate he
puts it hey he pretends he goes to ut
but he didn't go to [ __ ] ut
he didn't go to ut
texas volleyball national championship
volleyball's for [ __ ] like this guy
i didn't mean to be homophobic because
i love volleyball and i love i love gay
people
and i love i love texas and i'm sorry
for being homophobic
i'm not homo homo or so i don't know you
tell me
i'ma hope it's apm too i'm definitely a
homo sapien
and perhaps a homo homo sapien so
i'm sorry for being a douche bag just
then two seconds ago and i was
trying to act like i don't even know
where georgia tech's that
is in georgia how are the fellas tonight
handsy
like always barking hour they need to
ask for consent be a grower not a shower
[ __ ] man the future is unknown we just
gotta go with the flow